Here is my version of the function
for each of the characters we need to replace:
"&", ">". "<", "quote".
I replace it with is appropriate escaped version of the string.
I'm just overriding the same string, over and over again--
which is maybe not the finest way to do it
but it'll work, in our case.
And keep in mind that we need to replace
the ampersand first.
If you did it last, for example--
and I enumerated it last, to be a jerk--
you would replace ">" with ">"
and then you'd replace the ampersand in your new Escaped string
with an "&".
So let's test this a few times,
make sure it's working.
Okay. Obviously, it prints this test string test.
Let's give this one a test.
Okay. And this is what we get:
We see our "<" is Escaped to "<"
and our ">" is Escaped and so is our next "<" and our next ">".
Let's test the other ones, to make sure everything's working.
I'm going to get rid of these quotes and use single quotes instead
so we can test the escaping of those.
And what's the other one we didn't test? Aha!
Yes, we'll do our quiz from before:
& = &
And we'll see how this prints.
Okay. So here we go--Run.
We see our double quote was replaced with: "
and then our ampersand--
this was the quiz question we asked before--
so we have: & (which turns into one ampersand here) =& (that ampersand);
just: amp--for the letters a-m-p;
and then our closing quote.
Okay. So let me show you one other simpler way of writing this function.
We can replace most of this code--
like so.
We could say: import cgi.
As it turns out, this function is already included in Python:
cgi.escape (s, quote = True)
Otherwise, it doesn't Escape the quote
and--oops--let's return this.
Okay. So another way of writing this function is just to use the cgi module
that is included with Python, and let's give this a shot.
And, as you can see, it works just the same:
"hello, & --blah, blah, blah, blah-blah.
We see our Escape version of our string here, and this is obviously
a lot simpler than writing in your own.
You may need more functionality yours, if you want to do that in the future.
But for now, the built-in one will work just fine.
Okay. Good job.